first Minister you haven't had a phone
call with Liz truss since she became a
prime minister of course she said that
you should be ignored but did you expect
her to take that literally
not really um I should say as far as I'm
aware it's not just me I don't think
she's uh had a phone call with the Welsh
first Minister either certainly she
hadn't the last time I spoke to him look
it's just really unusual um I've listed
as the fourth prime minister that I've
dealt with as first Minister yeah let's
be honest We've Got Deep political
differences but David Cameron was in
office when I became first minutes I
think I spoke to him within hours of
becoming first Minister and then when
Theresa me and Boris Johnson became
prime minister I certainly within the
first couple of days we had a
conversation so it's just unusual that
Liz trust hasn't decided to do the same
thing why that is the case lacking
respect arrogance insecurity who knows
that's for her how did she compare to
the other three well I I don't really
know her because I've not had that
opportunity to engage but as the rest of
the public can see
um the decision she's taken in the first
few weeks over tenure is prime minister
have been utterly catastrophic to the
economy and to people across the country
who are paying the price of our
decisions in higher mortgage rate and
bordering course generally
next week we have the supreme court
hearing on another Independence
referendum if the Scottish government
loses that case will you stand down as
first most no
we stand in the next Hollywood elections
and that's my plan presumption
you answer these questions like a human
being rather than a rope
or so years away you know very few human
beings can see with certainty being
first minister is a massive job massive
responsibility has a big impact on your
own life your family's life I would owe
it to the Scottish people to make that
decision finally closer to the time if I
was to sit here and right now and say
absolutely no doubt come what me I'll be
standing next holy red election I think
people would have a right to be a grief
because it would suggest I wasn't taking
the job seriously enough but my
assumption is I'll Stand again and I'll
take that decision finally as we get
closer to that now you've criticized the
UK government today for a lack of
planning and basic communication on
energy supplies this winter are you
launching a public information campaign
on energy well we have various ways in
which we try to communicate with the
public around energy and other things
but can I just be clear here I support
Scottish independence and the Scottish
government having all of these
responsibilities but energy is a
reserved matter energy support
matter we will communicate carefully and
responsibly to the Scottish people as we
advise them over the winter we shouldn't
be in this position though the National
Grid helpfully I think issued its
different scenario we just studied the
the best Central scenario is that Supply
will meet demand over the winter but
from a Scottish perspective just take a
step back from this we had a net
exporter of electricity we already
generate sufficient Renewables to cover
almost 100 percent of our electricity
use we've got vast renewable potential
and yet we're in this position because
we are part of a GB grid and a reliant
on a UK government to take decisions
around this of having soaring Energy
prices and diminishing energy security
that says that there's a real problem
with the way these decisions are taken
right now that needs to be fixed but
you're not committing to a
Communications campaign we will have
communications campaigns yes I'm simply
not you know I don't want to sit here
and say it will take particular form but
we will communicate as we did throughout
the entirety of covet we will
communicate openly and candidly with
people about the pressures that have
been faced and what we are asking people
to do generally speaking right now not
just because of these potential supply
issues but because of environmental
issues because of the need to for people
to reduce energy costs we should all be
thinking about Energy Efficiency and how
we use energy responsibly cop 26 was
held in Scotland do you think the king
should attend to cop 27. I think it'd be
a good thing for the the king to be at
court 27 he was at Corp 26 the queen
obviously wasn't able to be there
personally but she gave a wonderful
address to to leaders
um and you know King Charles is somebody
who has out throughout his entire life
had a real concern for the environment
he's Head of State for many different
countries in the Commonwealth and I
think it would be entirely appropriate
should he want to to be at cup 27 and in
an independent Scotland who would be the
head of state you or King Charles I I
think you know I don't want to
personalize it may be up to people in
Scotland if we're independent to choose
their government but the position of my
party is that the the was the queen and
successors now the king and successors
would remain head of state because
Scotland would remain part of the
Commonwealth but that would be something
for future generations of Scotland of
Scots to continue to decide whether they
they were comfortable with but that is
the position of my party and is there a
sense almost eight years into your time
as first Minister that this abiding aim
throughout your political career of
leaving the UK of Scotland becoming an
independent country is looking really
quite difficult to achieve while you're
in office
um no I think Scotland is on a path to
being independent I hope that is sooner
rather than later because I think
well I do think it is entirely possible
that it will be well I'm first Minister
but actually for me that's not what is
most important it's not really that's
not not really it's Independence is not
about the personality of who is first
Minister it's not about me it's not
about my predecessors in this job it's
not about whoever will come after me
it's about what is right for Scotland
and what is right for Scotland in my
view is to be in charge of our own
destiny as an independent country like
the 200 or so other independent
countries across the world I hope not
for my sake I hope for the country's
sake that is within my tenure because I
hope it is soon but that for me is not
the most important issue who is first
Minister when happens in terms of your
own future will you go on and on
um that's not how I would choose to
freeze it because I because obviously
the test the history of a leader using
that phrase is not
and my planning assumption is that I
will fight the next Scottish election as
leader of the SMP and therefore seeking
another term is first Minister Mr
surgeon thank you thank you